leben auf dem mars weit der mars rover
curiosity auf dem roten planeten
unterwegs
mehrere wichtige indizien für mögliches
leben auf dem mars zumindest in früheren
zeiten steigen die chancen immer mehr
dass es zumindest mit proben oder
ähnliches gegeben haben könnte
nachdem der mars länder phoenix/2008 was
auf dem markt frei gebaggert hatte ist
der mars rover curiosity jetzt auch auf
einen alten wege stoßen warum die chance
auf leben erhöht jetzt in science
fiction herzlich willkommen
2008 war es die sensation zum ersten mal
konnten wir wasser auf dem mars sehen
also wassereis der mars länder felix
magath am 15 juni eis unter der
oberfläche frei für die
wissenschaftliche bestätigung wartete
die lava damals exakt vier tage dann war
klar als ein zweites foto von der stelle
zur erde übertragen worden war
das eis ist zum teil verdunstet es muss
wasserwand das war die absolute
sensation dann ende 2013 der mars rover
curiosity findet heraus dass der mars
bonin 2 prozent wasser enthält jetzt war
ein wichtiges problem einer zukünftigen
mars-mission gelöst wie brauchen nur
noch wasser für den hinflug auf dem mal
selbst und für den rückflug können wie
das wasser baut gewinnen
das macht eine mars-mission deutlich
günstiger bei tonnen an gewicht und
damit kosten gespart werden von dann an
war eine mars-mission deutlich
realistischer dann 2015 daten vom mars
reconnaissance orbiter werden analysiert
und es werden salzwasser bäche
identifizierten bäche wurden damals
schon weit länger beobachtet für ihn
stehen im mars früher werden immer
größer und verschwinden wieder im herbst
klettern die temperaturen auf dem mars
über null vermuteten die forscher
schmilzt dort wasser als die analyse der
daten des orbiters brachten dann die
beweise es handelt sich tatsächlich um
die vermuteten walze in diesem welchen
die in den trockenen bereichen nicht zu
finden wer so biologe louis d'or damit
die chancen auf leben in früheren zeiten
deutlich erhöht sie könnten ein zeichen
dafür sein dass es bakterien und
mikroben es leben dort gegeben haben
könnte und jetzt gibt es weitere
indizien für früheres leben auf dem mars
der mars rover curiosity durchquert
gerade einen in heiligensee und hat
bodenproben genommen sie untersuchten
proben aus verschiedenen tiefen gesehen
dabei stießen die forscher auf
verschiedene schichten von sedimenten in
den oberen schichten fanden sie mit
sauerstoff oxidierte verbindung und
tiefer waren die bedingungen deutlich
sauerstoff ärmer bedingungen genauso wie
auf der erde
wir haben jetzt zu der erstaunlichen
erkenntnis geführt dass das zeitfenster
für leben auf dem markt deutlich länger
ist als bisher gedacht laut den
forscherinnen und forschern gab es damit
auf dem markt lebensfreundliche
bedingungen zwischen 3,8 und 31
milliarden jahren
700 millionen jahre lang nach neuesten
forschungen auf der zeitraum in dem sich
auch hier auf der erde
das erste leben gebildet hat schon 200
millionen jahre nach der entstehung der
erde hat es hier bereits das erste leben
gegeben
die tat selbst als er sich schließlich
verdunstete gab es noch wesentliche
mengen grundwasser viel länger als wir
bisher gedacht haben dass verlängert das
fenster für eine mögliche existenz von
leben auf dem markt so jens freien wang
vom los alamos national laboratory aus
den usa
wenn es also auf dem mars ähnlich wie
auf der erde abgelaufen wäre
dann stehen die chancen nicht schlecht
vielleicht wie hier auf der erde
fossilien aus dieser frühzeit zu finden
was leben hier im sonnensystem und auf
der erde angeht passen die puzzleteile
immer besser zusammen wenn es wieder ein
neues puzzle teilchen in form von neuen
erkenntnissen zur außerirdischen leben
gibt dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier
nicht verpassen wollte wird merkt genau
hier ein abo auf auge und vergesst nicht
den auf die glocken ja hier geht es
weiter mit einem video genau zu diesem
thema fossilien geben hinweise auf
außerirdisches leben einfach
draufklicken wenn es euch interessiert
da geht es um die gerade eben erwähnten
neuen fossilen funde hier auf der erde
ja ansonsten bestand bleibt an